so William per seconds is a machine
learning engineer and curious person in
Orlando you grow up girl I know I
graduated to Duke he did some work at
the Howard Hughes Medical Institute
attributed to you peer-reviewed research
and deep learning computational
neuroscience is currently a freelance
data science consultant in the Orlando
area previously worked at Calculon wants
in credit cards and small business
lending and he's going to talk to us
about deep learning on mobile devices so
[Applause]
thank you so much Erin and thank you so
much to everyone here for making it out
tonight I'm really excited to be joining
all team to discuss deep learning
algorithms that can run on smartphones
and other hardware that is not as
computationally rich as a GPU which we
probably heard a lot about in the
context with the success of deep
learning over the past couple of years I
want to go to super detail right this
second but there have been a lot of
really fascinating and amazing advances
in the abilities of relatively simple
thoughts for computational hardware to
do especially image processing tasks and
basically anything else that the
mornings been applied to you but I'm
mainly going to be focused on in the
recognition and a little bit of authors
detection because that is especially
relevant for smartphones we have a
camera and we're totally familiar with
probably how certain
the technology there could work out so I
to start off I some acknowledgments a
little more thank you of course and also
to Tito and Erin for putting this
together and the analytics meetup here
the group here in Miami and the various
organizations of meetup groups so that
there's a new high data of Miami
organization that kind of started with
it's great also I mentioned Serena box
turaga screening was my first academic
advisor actually not my first
technically I did some research in
college as well but as Erin was
describing a couple years ago I worked
in research in a research lab as a
research assistant and software engineer
in a deep burning research lab and it
was Serena who brought me on that's kind
of this banging computational guru he
has been that he was working and deep
warning before it was called that and
actually left the field because there
were no jobs and deep waiting for him to
do so we did post talks of other fields
that came back to deep learning later
really amazing guy also my family and
friends of course and can't go without
thanking Wikipedia or archive as well I
mean I probably learned can work on
Wikipedia than maybe humans experience
itself and so why should this talk
interest you I know you're already here
so we have kind of a selection effects
where you are
our dear I wish I could talk to them as
well but yeah they're dead there are as
I was alluding to earlier there have
been a number of developments in not
just deep learning as an overall yield
in terms of theirs I'm not even gonna go
over the whole area cuz I couldn't even
do that anyway
but specifically for running on things
as slow as your phone there have been a
lot of improvements in algorithms which
I'll be going over that probably the
most of the focus of my talk
unfortunately I'm actually not gonna be
sharing any code this is all mainly
going to be how things work certain
advances that have happened that enable
smaller number of architectures that can
achieve levels of performance that used
to be the state of the art on GPUs and
but also there have been so I suppose
we've gotten faster batteries have
gotten better what else I have actually
a few things here cameras on folks are
getting better and now they're there to
be it's more common now for folks to
have multiple cameras which then enables
new types of depth perception and images
in a way that enables perhaps to do
applications of using of a smart phone
using AI and also with as far as likely
possibilities and spill owers what one
of the possibilities yeah now we we're
not really enslaved just using GPUs
anymore we can we can use these
algorithms in our pocket and in terms of
spill over with other industries and so
on I was thinking this is wondering that
I talk
and then to the top but I think it's
very important because it's really about
application and why this is relevant not
just academically though that's
interesting as well but in terms of how
this can make the world a better place
so things about like robotics Internet
of Things any sort of hardware that has
sensing involves like a nest in your
home like those little smart sensors
really in any device that people that is
marketed as smart today I mean with this
type of stuff that it could that could
run a simple what does it call the guys
integrated circuit on that device be
much smarter like what we are calling a
smart fridge today
it thinks if a fridge could use other
detection internally to know exactly the
cursor ease you have and how old they
are and forecast when they're going to
go bad and that's something that
creatures aren't doing today but it
probably could that's a it's a it's a
market opportunity that I don't know
some of you may want to start a business
in this and and develop some of these
some these products these I do this is
one reason why I'm actually working in
this area right now full disclosure and
interested in starting a business using
this technology which is why I have an
obsessed with it recently so and a
couple other ideas oh yeah self-driving
cars this is probably the number one
area that has a application air that's
been driving a lot of research in this
area is people using the cloud takes too
long to get feedback for an ultimate
vehicle one event is are having on
device algorithms is that you have a
bunch of shorter latency there are other
advantages as well or say also clear but
as far as applications where you need
immediate feedback and need to make
decisions very quickly based on
information about your surroundings you
honest Asian to understand this as
algorithms get smaller and run a smaller
hardware to enables things like
self-driving cars that can have a small
computer in them or drones or any sort
of other autonomous stain like something
that is a easy piece of already out
there things that clean floors they they
go over I've seen these Rubens Roomba
exactly thank you are they using deep
learning to useful sort of inference
visually or probabilistically - I'm not
sure I have one in my house I don't
think they have a camera builds in very
sort of other sensing big it has some
rudimentary sense I robot those do some
rudimentary really ok they learn not
only your floor and they also learn
different time and they have they're
working on one because iRobot the CEO is
a lady and they're working on the
military version of the iRobot and the
claws is the same source code and yeah
they're working on all right I mean and
they basically have the CPU of the phone
yes okay yeah so that's a great example
that's already in production already
little mini militaries and people's
phones like that is it an actual
military application or is this serve
their building military they're the kind
of thing security robots understand ok
so this is yeah I'm sure that there are
especially in military applications
where you know like with just drones
that are in combat this is already being
used I personally don't know anything
about that makes a comment they're
actually looking at they have a robot
that looks like a garbage can that roams
around places like we did see in Publix
and actually their camera can detect or
sense of a person
shop with based on by how they they act
so it kept the robot detect whether
somebody's doing something suspicious
and I also turn ice eighty sixty camera
and phone home and say hey you know it
looks something suspicious here yeah
again very simple CPUs because they have
to be battery-powered
what they do is scan on your home and
they look okay this is a sofa this is
the table oh they missed in the chair
can we then send them an email to get
this question arose do they want to
write a chair and so they're thinking on
that level of how to use that right yeah
that makes sense to anomaly detection
for you should buy this thing to not be
anomalous anymore something like that
yeah so thanks for by the way for
Kenneth chipping in we can get some
others hey Jack yeah so yeah so also
wanted to touch on other technologies
and where analogous technologies in the
past and wearing things today's
technology is compared to where other
technologies were in the past so we
think about the transistor which is
hugely transformative as a as a
technology when it was first discovered
well when was anything in the late
forties and early fifties it was a super
crappy technology didn't work very well
but eventually you know people made it
work a little better and then transistor
radios came about an interesting story
about these I heard is that the main
technology that they eventually replaced
vacuum tube technologies for
all the manufacturers of vacuum tube
technologies vacuum tubes rather we're
not interested in all the transistors
because they weren't as good as back in
juice for the applications that were
they were mainly used for and of course
at first you know the transistors then
it enabled an application that wasn't
possible before like a pocket radio and
then gradually the technology improved
over time and kind of took over a whole
a whole new market so literally I think
with client-side web technology
applications like I great that when the
the foundries in Salesforce weren't went
to try to get venture funding venture
capitalists and say why why should we
invest in you you're making an
application that runs in a browser and
browsers aren't very fast will
eventually browsers got faster the whole
ecosystem of technologies got faster
Java that email or JavaScript and jQuery
and broadband became more and more
available and it's similar thing I think
is happening with mobile devices
hardware is improving the tools in the
ecosystem of actually deploying these
algorithms to phones is improving we
have every few months tenser close
releasing some new toolkit or the sub
library or tool sing with PI torch there
are tools for converting neural nets
between floor mats to make them
available to this type of file under
that type of both different phone
manufacturers are like there's now corn
mm uh Iowa's I think or ml has existed
for a while but they're adding new
subroutines specifically for deep
learning to make common operations like
convolutions be more efficiently
implemented on bachelor hardware
architecture so these is kind of what
happened with GPUs honestly
ten years ago with CUDA
when before CUDA people have GPUs but
there was a really an easy way to take
advantage of them and then when order
for them to become useful new sets of
tools that to be introduced to make it
easier for people to make products that
took advantage of that technology that
is happening right now in this space
that's part of predators and why I kind
of have a little bit of urgency with
this topic because it's a really special
time I really feel this way I'll take a
little bit of goosebumps I get that way
with some things it's a little different
epilady I know but I can think that
we're especially with with with AI that
can run on our own hardware many
wearables or agricultural devices that
can farm for us and not have to rely on
large tech companies to do all the
compute for us and data centers I think
a new new types of applications are
coming about perhaps also similarly with
laptops and laptops we're first coming
out you know these are these are things
that I didn't want to say this you know
people said that these technologies
sucked when they first come out okay now
we heard that they weren't fast enough
they the batteries didn't last long but
things are improving with time so I
think that's kind of where we are in our
with this technology and maybe now that
we I have some demos wondering what it
makes sense for me to kind of go over
that
right now okay yes I want to go over the
rest of the top tell madam time yeah
Maybelline I'm gonna focus on algorithms
also there's hardware tools already
talked a little bit about some
implications for what it means for what
certain things can be created in the
future and also there's some I have some
ideas for maybe where well I I've seen
some recent papers that are coming out I
have some inside and see what
researchers are trying methods and
approaches that they're taking to
improve these algorithms as well which
is very interesting as we'll get to
later here we go yeah so sorry I don't
know why there's this there's not but
those the it's the history is so brief
and it's still happening that there's a
third dot that's not quite done yet so
excuse me is what that means
so most progress has occurred relatively
recently and most of the advances in in
algorithms have been kind of adaptations
of taking ideas people come up before to
make larger nets more effective more
accurate and kind of either just
directly downsizing them or kind of
trying to understand why they're working
so well and then kind of move them
around in the way such that maybe they
can make just like a smaller net
architecture work you know like much
really high above it whatever that
expression is like do really well and so
in case anyone here is kind of really
deep learning this when we get like a
brief recap is kind of how we got to
where we are
this is kind of funny I saw this today I
looked on the archives in the air times
yeah - here this is 2012 this was back
when the first big neural net called
Alex ed came out they said I'm here who
here has heard of Alex net okay yeah so
about like 30 so Alex net was the name
of her Alex chesty who is the lead
author on the first convolutional neural
network that was successfully trained to
really do super well on image
recognition and prior to this contest
people have had a really hard time
getting them to to Train like you can
train them but they may be the network
parameters were really unstable so they
wouldn't converge or there are a variety
of things that weren't working Bennett
was there a few recent improvements to
practice that algorithmically and also
what they know they tried doing which
worked really well was using GPUs so a
big thing oh yeah also the big aspect
was there was a huge amount of data that
became available in 2009 it actually
happened in Miami this like super
erector looking that is a very important
conference have a great way I'm really
happy to hear that so we have this this
data set called image net when it came
out it was database of a million images
thousand images in a thousand categories
and it was it was really important to
have this because until recently it's
been like really important to have a lot
of data
neural nets because they have so many
parameters there's need more examples
and so this female that really helped a
lot with with research that was a that
was unveiled here man enough to fire
compress this is when Alec tech came out
this is what the architectural look
liked and basically you take an image
which may be how it has like three
channels so rather blue and green and
you you learn a head of spatial patterns
in succession and that's what these are
doing where they're looking at little
patches old local patches of the image
and they will be kind of detect in these
early they got layers I want to talk too
much about this was imagine people here
are pretty cool a visitor or happy at
least but in early layers of an era lab
at typically you're it's picking up on
things like just normal edges as you get
further later as in if you start
conferring things like curvature or
circles or massive geometric structure
as you get further on from there you'll
learn things like maybe a face like as a
composition of a certain geometric
structures and a certain spatial
configuration in a way that maybe if
you're looking at a painting of the cop
so if you it would be recognizable
because in cubism this is because it has
an artistic side there here it's kind of
this this spatial reconfiguration of
some ability American geometric shapes
but it eases its learning a certain
abstract concepts you can view as
compositions of increasingly simple
geometric structures and that's how
having these little patches enabled in
able to just kind of learn those those
patterns and then eventually get into
yeah I'm not going to talk about that
never Alex
there's a flurry of new vignettes and I
say big steak really where pick this one
it requires I think about 2 gigabytes on
the GPU which for a two-dimensional
image classic iris I think it was
biggest that existed but it was also the
best and so and every wanted to do the
party big standby few teams because also
this year I'm going to talk a bit about
some later dances as I lived earlier
they were most what most of the recent
work and small internal events they
basically mainly been adapting
innovations of larger ones and what's
happened since basically since this one
we're out 2014 I think when it came out
it's mainly now that about being works
lever with the types of structures that
are in the neural net architecture no
that's a not supporting where it's
really kind of sad then used to be very
simple in this way or motifs stacked on
the illusions of each other now they're
so complicated or kind of complicated if
you study them for a while eventually
they kind of make sense I'm going to try
to go through that so they became very
accurate this is how accurate a neural
net was able to classify an image and
that image that database so it started
out the orthotics Madden 55 accuracy was
considered amazing
now by the way infos can do about here
and a very fast frame rate it's pretty
good you can use were very important
they got a lot better over time there's
really good friends and in stock price
this is a yeah that's a kind of better
year but also in addition GPUs as I was
saying Alex met some really important
algorithmic innovations happened around
the same time so I'd say this is it's
trying to kind of move away from oh
everything's about GP uses algorithms re
I think arguably much more important yes
we have deep learning revolution because
of GPUs but as we know now we kind of
didn't ever need to be used if research
had continued at the same pace maybe by
now actually with the smaller neural
nets that are doing really well we could
have kind of been achieving the same
accuracy by now anyway early sort of
smaller nets so I don't know how many
here how many people here to drop out
Fannin's late okay yeah cool yeah so
these things were also very important
that's really big
this gives you an idea how big these
these vgg that's where the visual
geometry group they come out with these
and actually now you can kind of see I
wish I could I couldn't find an image
that old they kind of have some of the
older next foot if you can actually see
there's some very small Nets that we
call these are a little bigger but look
at little that be do this came out about
week once again this is a tiny net and
it's doing about 72 percent accuracy on
the on the nut top five different ways
of measuring actually this is the
strictest way of measuring accuracy and
it's doing better than these behemoths
we're doing just about less than five
years ago yeah
number of parameters the memory that it
takes up on on a computer and these
devices tire these are these nets Alex
Mack was about something like twenty
eight billion parameters these other
ones they're like less than two percent
of they're like 40,000 parameters a
number of parameters but it's a good
question
deserve for any ways to quantify this
people want to fly them in terms of how
many images can you classify per second
like how how much how much time as I can
take to classify an image or how much
memory it takes up how many
floating-point operations there are
they're taking place to run through that
I think the probably the most objective
is e is the floating point operations
are multiplied and the number of
multiply and add operations that
occurred I think that's the only type of
operation to happen in place they're
also comparisons significant cooling
layer yes there's also invariance in
operations but multiply add is the
metric that I mainly seen in the
literature is talking about like how big
that's are and that is quite small this
is
this is on image that there's so this is
the thousand category and that was
things like different dog breeds a boat
yeah yeah yeah so what happened as
accuracy density was pretty low accuracy
densities a way of kind of quantifying
for each additional parameter you add to
your model what's the incremental
benefit in terms of accuracy that you
get like how efficient your model is
that ain't good
get away and he's like I'm really like
giving these guys a hard time the
Pichichi like way up here and then that
we come here we have these like little
nuts these like bubble that v1 what
would that be to squeeze that very
recently so yeah we had high accuracy
required okay so that's kind of where to
get into what I think's been happening
recently in a small net space so when
it's about 2016
there have been instead of this that's
getting bigger that kind of a getting
smarter so in the first area here I'm
going to go to the next slide here what
aspect is connections between layers and
what these mainly did was they enabled
nest be very deep because the issue was
you just had a simple neural net that
was really deep it wouldn't converge
like once you got once you did back
propagation through the layers during
that once you got a certain number of
layers the gradients beginningless the
ingredients been stable so we stabilized
ingredients to add more connections
between layers and that's what a fence
mended residual connections as well
residual connections
that's that was as he gave her the name
that's Lily had a connection like every
layer in the network but actually when
it came out it was the most accurate net
that I think this to that time for a
little while and also their goodies very
clever or complicated later models were
instead of just having the convolutions
and max pooling layers being one on top
of the other we have these new types of
relatively new ways of capturing the
kind of abstractions that I was talking
about it beginning of what's happening
at each individual layer and this is not
totally very well understood why these
work so well but basically what people
do think is they're definitely nailing
some sort of dimensionality reduction
and I'm not going to go too much into
some more like mathematical ravings of
this but this enables you to use your
parameters to capture a very rich kind
of parameterization of different ideas
you have about the world at that level
of abstraction also people did some kind
of tweaks with the individual with
simple operators actually kind of I
don't know this may sound scary to some
people but I swear it's not it's just a
poorly chosen pretentious made also
there's been a this is a very
interesting area of research automated
architecture search where basically net
designed to Heaven gamified and with all
this is advances that have happened and
things like alphago or health ago all
the coast
this one the reinforcement learning or
Atari using reinforcement learning and
also genetic algorithms which are
relating to but they have kind of people
have been able to stout different net
architectures and find what is actually
best architecture of her you can also
apply a budget but how many parameters
you want you can say well keeping my net
not any bigger than this number of
parameters this is the best that I could
possibly have and it will search a space
and on that a little later and there
have been other ones do residual tension
through a clutter so here's this thing
here where instead of this having two
layers stacked on each other this is how
things were previously with HoloNet or
Eugenia cetera they have every two
layers actually take the output from one
layer and have it as another input to
the next set of things that's this a
nice way of kind of adding a another
kind of just like stabilizes the data
that's flowing through it makes sure
that things don't explode or diminish I
will be great dance and that we're
really able to have like next our
hundreds of layers be also first with a
larger
protectors they did these things called
expert physical blocks where as you can
see here you have to say like the layer
that has a like a large number of
dimensions instead of just doing a some
convolutions on that large dimension a
large dimensional space right away
actually collapse it down to you our
number of dimensions then do a
convolution and then we expand it back
out which is a really clever trick and
this will love my abundance it's it's
not a it's called a point wise
convolution which is a term that I don't
like it's not actually a convolution
it's just taking all of the channels at
that individual point and just applying
like a matrix multiplication just like a
mapping from one number of dimensions to
another number of dimensions like in
matrix multiplication of the colinear
group and that works really well this is
also kind of relevant for this like
second category of innovations that I
mentioned earlier with learning about
like reducing dimensionality and having
more interesting more like doing doing
fewer convolutions and revolutions on
attributes or latent attributes that are
like more important interesting
compressing data within your your neural
net and then Bracy this is going to be
used in one really nice architecture
that's really small well also there are
these so now I'm going to go into this
it's deep obligated and I need to go
faster oh yeah automated architecture
researchers I just love this topic at
automatic circuit because it sounds so
stupid it's like okay all these genius
people they came up with these
architectures
let's just like train a lot to like find
the best
and it works it's like they've made I
mean they had to do some very kind of
special things you have to in order to
be able to search get into kind of like
parametrize a search space it's not that
easy to do when you consider how kind of
categorical and it's not like you can
just parameterize or how much should I
say this variety of neural nets you can
have it's like very easy you can't just
I don't know how to say a big if they
came up with this way though of
searching through a small dimensional
space that made the exploration problem
more tractable this is what I write and
they use the kind of exploration that
they did remaining there's some people
who've done reinforcement learning how
people use genetic approaches and maybe
do a train like hunt ten like a hundred
thousand neural nets and figure out
which one was the best
Bayesian optimization it's a little
different but that has also been used
burning like how you choose the right
learning rate people use Bayesian
optimization to off to my stack for
example that's kind of a related topic
oh yeah so these are this was kind of a
previous state of the art I think this
was about a year ago that all this came
out and and you can also do this here I
think that here they have oh yeah multi
multiple supply and add operations this
is what else getting to getting an
earlier so when you say we restrain
yourself to a very small bet they are
able to actually find in that that had
seventy-four percent accuracy with a
very small number of
e10 only got about a thousand with it's
a little billion volt supply at
operations
so before eight get gigaflop or we're
going to do that or I don't know how
long it takes I think it's very fast
oh so these are few of the small neural
net set of come out I will talk about
this one next
I'm not going to talk about all these I
mean a second you just won this one and
on this one and but there been some
other ones as well but basically they've
taken part some idea from some big
dancing that kind of transferred it down
and with vocal bets this is about two
years ago plus fifty years ago you can
see here that for a very small model
compared to say even even this one here
probably a few years ago they have you
know 30 the number of math if they do
it's still more accurate down here it's
a very small number this is 0.5 is like
a factor that they have for adjusting
how big this is small that is you have a
very small network that actually - this
is about 500 million this is if you have
just seven people in operations you can
actually have a accuracy that is better
than what I expected
with like 50 times as many parameters
pretty amazing and this was not even
that recent this was about 20 months ago
and all only did was they just took a
normal convolution did it in Spokeo the
depth wise publishes it's a good normal
convolution just typically going to take
certain number of input channels
convolve them spatially and convert that
into another number
chance and what they did was they first
said let's actually instead of doing
this big convolutional block let's just
learn one flat convolution for each
individual channel do that
and then do one of these simple just
dimensionality change both of matrix
multiplication things the point wise
convolution said we talked about earlier
and that's enough to reduce competition
by the law you have a free binary
convolution just the most common size
thanks that means you're doing the tenth
the computation which is really nice and
basically almost the same accuracy and
this is kind of like different how how
they're different so this is a normal
full tool pollution diversity that
channel wise they say that Y is how to
make channel wise but things just
weren't your blame for putting grease
for it this channel I'm going to do one
population it's a very simple the slow
little matrix patch and then do that for
each Channel and then maybe increase
that under conventions or shrink after
the back and this is a way in a way kind
of reducing the rank of the convolution
that you're doing as well so it's like
introducing this kind of regularization
to the convolution see reply which layer
so has because it's less complex and
another more recent innovation will
allow me to develop excellent seen in
Google they basically also did you tweak
how big it is they dislike show that
well if any kind of variable size and
trade-off for one date in terms of how
big your model is and how accurate
is how accidents that they're the best
so this was the original global net
the second version has a higher accuracy
it has fewer parameters who are
operations and it's faster and this was
actually it's also better than the
reinforcement learned automated search
model which is kind of interesting so
there's still hope for the rest of us
our jobs are not automated yet people
human beings are still developing better
neural nets then the robots are now so
yes it's so extended the campuses
this is the same error metric let's talk
about the beginning it's in the earlier
slide this is 75% accuracy and this was
a year ago there have been I'm not going
to go to some of the other ones but
there have been some even more recently
that are even better and so things are
getting better and better on these tiny
so I don't know how much I'm not going
to go into the detailed list but just
kind of qualitatively what is happening
is a very similar in a way kind of the
similar thing is with what it's enabling
you to do is it's they're doing this
here this is the original residual block
which I touched on earlier here it's say
if you had like that layer with a 256
dimensions you can reduce the
dimensionality then do a convolution if
that reduces the nationality space and
then re-expand leader this is actually
took that idea and they turned it around
we're actually they take a small
dimensionality space they expand it then
they do some very simple pom illusions
only depth wise convolutions they do
this is the stupid
which is support computational engine
and then they get those and then they
collapse it again afterward and turns
out works really well and that's how
they were able to everyone so they where
it's so he's either kind of different
sizes I think of their their model or
size of size and as you can see the the
one that the robots made this Nash net
girl are necrosearch that is up here and
there like a little better so they want
and there are others I'm not going to go
into them but yeah let's shuffle that
thing out of for recent and people
basically that kind of slide in the
middle of those talking about they're
either using and becoming up what kind
of a different and marvels in neural net
second of reduced dimensionality in
subway were making some of the
fundamental operations were
computational there are also things
people done with likes living and
network like iteratively
yeah sorry and oh yeah another kind of
related areas object detection so people
kind of like give example I'm gonna stop
actually
I'm actually gonna live cast my phone
where I have some small nets that are
able to run why
okay that's why can we identify it here
we go this work perfect so yeah right
here you can see this is this is
actually mobile net running on my phone
so you can see it's we're maybe in a
library yeah let's see the water bottle
my or a big job taking forty percent
sure what it thinks this is dumbbell
okay that's actually a tested but yeah
so this is kind of an example of the
kind of accuracy and speed you can't see
the latency on the bottom there it's
running pretty fast
this was ago your refresh might be
hurting it - yeah it might actually be
doing it and the i/o straining video but
yeah this is uh that's that one and then
also you can have a author detector
which can identify chairs and people can
see new things or here and this is as
much slower meaning you know one or two
frames a second but like it's not
earlier it's kind of a sliding scale
again you can choose trade-offs in terms
of how fast accurate if you want things
to be so then wants to see more on this
way oh that's great to use how much
better you use that's a great question
that's the main thing that's really yeah
are you gonna go into how he's built out
alright he going to how he built out
it's not a high level detail is that
like a z-score ml or what did you what
did you want it easy yeah so it's
there's actually a nice tool you can use
to you who is asking me right yeah okay
sorry there's this nice utility you can
use to if you train the network and say
hi porridge or tensorflow or cafe you
can convert it to corn MLS compile Titan
and then package that and a sip will
happen for most there are few exceptions
of business work out of the box the same
thing where is some text that doesn't
work is it use a kind of special
fundamental operator like maybe a
certain type of pooling lawyer or
cooling operator or something that maybe
Coronel doesn't have an implementation
for but basically yeah just what I did
is I I didn't even train the model I
just found the model middle tab and then
I converted it and put it in this Xcode
project I'm not even I got it I wish I
need more iOS development is really like
this I can actually how to make apps but
for making something simple like the
demo just uses the camera does that
answer your question isn't because you
have so many features in there with the
app so did you build these demos just
for this Meetup I made those for today
yeah I made it two hours ago
I made this like two or three weeks ago
that's cool yeah so thanks and also in
that's a lot of code you can copy on the
Internet few other people are doing this
but a fun thing about this area too is
it's not like a hundred thousand people
on the Internet are doing the same thing
it's like a few people which is kind of
promising from a it's like okay I'm not
like but you can actually get into this
space and you want to person people
working in this space so detection is
like its own separate task yes sir oh
yeah that was Yolo Yolo be free yeah
yeah yeah I'm I recommend by the way if
you ever want to see the most hilarious
academic article you've ever seen so
look up the paper for this it didn't
actually go to a journal so if you Blake
just was like super but yes Yolo I'm
familiar with how the original Yola
works generally well basically reframes
the object detection problem is a
regression problem and says that you
know it says okay you're next certain
boxes of widths and Heights and centers
and basically just Waring's to predict
values and justice uses normally friggin
lost predicts values of boxes the it
just goes all through in one and one go
it doesn't need any other
here's a start with an initial guess and
then they use that initial guess update
the guests with additional information
which actually is more accurate than
yellow but it can be slower but actually
what these people did here the leg that
thing they actually figured out they
took a little tickle took a look at what
was causing some of these multi-state or
Tuesday atomic attackers to be slower
than yellow until a list of the fastest
figured out how to make the two-stage
ones faster and made this and that's
important because the two-stage ones are
more accurate now single-shot ones but
most people seem to like there's more
written in blogs and stuff about yellow
but I wonder if that's because the OL
owners has a trendy day I think nobody
wants to read about life that are seeing
that yeah and the nice thing with these
as well as the
most of the architecture for section you
can kind of plug in play with a
different base events so say bubble net
v3 comes out you can take a someone can
train look at that net on some other
data set and then you just kind of add
on a layer to things to kind of make the
objects a protection part work train
those bits on here your favorite data
set and and you're ready to go so that's
it's a nice kind of extension of all the
other work that's happening so to get to
what the troll was asking about
batteries yeah so the main cause of
doing on device any sort of computation
that gets really hot just keep learning
is that there are obviously accuracy is
one issue because your
dealing with smaller hardware but also
battery life gets drained pretty quickly
for the mobile for the bull den thing
the first step of the negative which is
constant updating that actually doesn't
take up that much compute perhaps also
someone was mentioning maybe some of the
right way time has be consumed by video
capture or something that's not
necessarily compute related but the
yellow version that I have here if I
start my battery at 20% and run that app
my phone is dead in like 15 minutes
you do the math not that I trust that
percentage indicator on my iBook do the
math basically means you can run the app
for an hour and 15 minutes and that's
the goodbye battery but batteries are
getting better so I think people tell me
they're getting better and so that's one
thing that is a concern but there are
ways around it yeah so also the next day
with one device I saw the demo it's
really fast
you got immediate feedback you can if
you need feedback within 50 milliseconds
you know you can you know have a design
your net to be even faster or you need
things to be more accurate you only need
an update every second you can do that
as well
also from well-being the spices you're
not paying a dime to run any of these
algorithms because you're it's like
bring your own computer your customers
are computing things for you with your
your company running this you can
doesn't require internet also data that
has it has been theory you can have an
app where data never leaves your device
which is your customer is someone who
cares about about that maybe it's a
enterprise customer who
let's have a really secure application
or you know paranoid consumer who
doesn't want it
you know there is what we're really
curious about privacy that's a little
bit like being a little cutie with that
but yeah it's um that's a certainly not
a disadvantage so perhaps more in
general aware that would be useful
we've got a tight group with
applications say in general I think it's
situations especially where it's like a
mechanical situation maybe we need
immediate feedback so things go to the
next slide
like say you're driving or biking and
maybe you can have your phone set up
that is looking behind you and it's
maybe slave speaking things that it sees
or something
or if you're a bike game like a maybe
you can have this thing on the front of
gear of your of your bike and it detects
apples or something and yeah we're going
to play you use your phone
in conjunction with some sort of other
mechanical actuator like robotics x3
years whether hardware accessory also
live music chatter agent I can imagine
being kind of interesting like something
that recognizes what you know amela de
we're gonna so like recognizing the
belly like oh that's you know this
particular song but something that can
recognize the goods that you singin like
adding percussion or something recently
a research group somewhere was project
magenta
where there they developed a plug-in for
Ableton that can automatically generate
percussion tracks for any song that
you're composing in Davidson and I've
gotta know that somewhat very simple
version of that perhaps an app where
you're sending something automatically
create percussion and having that low
latency isn't really important there if
you used the infrastructure where it's
running in the cloud and then having to
wait a second to get a response from
somewhere else work very well and also
essentially you know small autonomous
entities self-driving cars are pretty
big but and where maybe a certain level
of accuracy very high a big requires
very high level of accuracy but perhaps
for certain consumer kind of fun devices
whether it's like a remote-control car
or drown or something that you can mount
a smartphone with it to kind of be the
brains for that that device oh yeah
please just kind of like applications of
the pros and cons to like well okay one
comment was that a nice battery so where
could it be useful where power source
available like in your car or your work
or if you're asleep
you know and your thumb is charging or
something like that and in order to grab
up really quick with some kind of it
gives where things could be heading so
in terms of research I'm not a
researcher but if I were a grad student
I would maybe be wondering like okay one
thing that's interesting about having a
small simple model is that be useful in
ensemble situations you think about
gradient boosting with reading booster
decision trees the base classifiers are
very
classifier operant types stops are used
in gradient boosting maybe with neuron
that spit is it possible to use a very
simple based classifier are really
stupid neural net but do boosted that's
about savile of nets for each net
offsets for errors made by other nets a
ensemble or random decision that's as
well you have a little bit of net that
has a really high variance because like
certain decision tree models they employ
you know each different nodes and the
trees only look at certain features some
people have certain types of the middle
that's where you know the ramp extremely
random decision uh neural nets where
each point in like the units in say
layers of your girl that you're only
considering us a random subset of
features that are coming or channels
that are coming from the previous layer
that could be something that would be
interesting and where the individual
individual members of the ensemble are
not accurate but where did they together
are able to be very accurate people I
perhaps people already included that's
about this also using architect research
there is some meta learning happening
there also how do you here's heard of a
few shopping you shot learning
conservator so with face ID on your
phone you think about how how if these
face it he is accomplishing it's only
looking at your face a couple times and
is able to recognize you there after
it's even able to recognize you in
different lighting conditions
if you dye your hair different color the
thing it's also in
it's an age and how your face will look
different in different age or with
makeup I mean they have to be in
marriage things like makeup as well and
these sort of things I would I would
vary for the same identity a person they
they're able to see past that and by
just looking up a few examples and that
area that problem is called few shop
learning where you're basically able to
classify learning literally a good
classifier or a specific category just
based on a few examples and this only
typically works for problems that are
very domain specific so it works with
things like faces faces are also very
study area and machine learning so we we
know a lot about a lot of work has been
done in recognition so it's a small nets
yeah it's impossible to potentially
train smaller deaths from some sort of
super intelligent larger net that is
running somewhere else yeah so in one of
your slides you had the different
optimizations for mobile Knut v1 v2
versa you know the whole history right
like but you know with the coming 5g
world we ended this year next year in
fact today I just finally noted some ATT
I saw a 5g he and ever seen that before
maybe it's like good coincidence that
happen
like so what optimizations are could be
changed with better connectivity to your
mobile phone that previously were
optimized for low maybe low connectivity
well actually I think 5g enables
streaming of video to the cloud or
easily in a way it means that on the
bias perhaps you know optimize
computation as is less there may be some
situations where on device doesn't make
as much sense you would still have to be
the conversation will still have to be
running somewhere but one thing I can
imagine 5g being useful for for even on
a device computation is if you're
running underling out on your phone
actually getting updates from a server
about how that neural net should be
different based on what you're looking
at transport it down to basically
downloading new ways downloading or
maybe you're in a new situation and you
want to classify something better that
you don't have a classifier or maybe get
like download a new bottle and it would
be a one-time transfer question question
comment I've done that a question
because we we have servers and we use AI
for managing servers and we went to
small and how so any is AI administers
the amount server security with updates
new users there's we have like eight
different small networks that control
the servers one master network that
manages them
lack of a better word and we have
multiple servers and we went and the
reason I'm here as a matter of fact is
because we don't use GPUs at all I mean
these are regular everyday computers
yeah
so we've optimized but but we see good
run stuff like this on CPUs they're
running on regular CPUs and they're
small Nats right so the interesting
thing is we have computers and grid
computer grid we have like 13 or 14 all
over the world and we're using the high
speed network so let the day ice talk to
each other yeah well for example let's
say somebody tries to hack a server in
suite boasts work the servers in Miami
and Dallas find out about it and as they
together doesn't need the patterns of
what people are doing for hacking not
just what they do but how they do it and
we establish patterns between them all
over the world right so we're so this
small a eyes are actually talking to
each other learning from each other so
that if somebody attacks Sweden right
from China or Protector let's say
they're pretending to be from France but
they're really from China next time they
attack Dallas even though they're
pretending to be from Italy we still
know that it's coming from China have to
synchronize and tolerance basically
exactly so going back to the phone that
5g will give you the ability for
multiple for multiple eyes to work as
one and that that's something that's
actually pretty scary but think about it
you may be running an AI and your phone
but in reality we've been all be running
the same AI you know Lisa B Google or
whatever not part client-server so parts
running on the cloud parts running and
they I mean that's the future but that's
the capability of what's happening the
5g that's why 5g such a big thing
because it gives you basically a little
unlimited bandwidth or as much as they
want to sell you on your phone and yes
you can do a lot with very little AI
with very little CPU power if you're
controlled what you're doing with it you
know try to do everything yeah yeah but
you are more intelligent of how you use
that resource yeah so my question for
you was when you're running the
application do you know how many CPUs
because in nowadays all these you know
two CPUs four CPUs how many cores you're
actually is that program running on only
one core
I know it's using a bowl with another
editing the really cool thing about
smart CPU they're not actually use the
GPU and the CPU is in the same chip
right so it's running on the GPU
okay I don't know it depends it depends
on the FCC to use pencil right so I was
wondering it was using all of them or
just using one of them well judging from
how fast my battery died I think it's
using quite a few years ago is the
latest Apple makes the size things they
have like Mineiro beep engine yeah
yeah and I imagine an iPad for example
it would be faster as well yeah but I
aspire I was like which what how it's
using the hardware and I'm not sure but
Apple really the nice thing with this
technology is the wind is on our backs
Apple wants to make this work as well as
possible on their hardware cos either
Google's going to make something better
or they are they want to use all the
compute available and provide efficient
implementations
that's run as fast as possible
what are your thoughts on when we're
talking about small Nesbit army closing
right now my load is why some point they
are classes by publicly questions they
were designed with machine learning
capturing the probably everything that I
said about saying smartphone an
etiquette
I say smartphone because it's a example
of little hardware basically though you
didn't all I mean also it's based upon
GPU deep learning in a way so yeah these
headsets I don't know what what sort of
hardware they're endowed with what sort
of processing power they have but also I
don't know how battery life works with
that or examinations or
okay yes I mentioned they're doing a lot
of other computation to you so this
isn't necessarily a huge
probably that it's an object detector
like yellow you're gonna need the
Integra this was okay that's the that's
the harbor that they're good ship that
they're using in that that's that yeah
was a [ __ ]
yeah medically has a small PC basically
these immediate agro base you see you
just it's like an expandable thing like
op1 have a basket process where you just
lay put in this thing
yes it's connected to some kind of
processor make sure they need it yeah
great yeah that's yeah that's an area
that frankly I don't know much about but
if there's this object detection AR
and actually yeah I mean no people are
still making huge Nets I mean with you
here's her advance
the and stuff they have so Gans are
these amazing incredible is generating
examples of images generally images that
look plausible that look like they could
have been taken by a camera in the real
world and in order to do that kind of
generation of images including very
high-resolution images you need you need
a really big model you need to be able
to capture very fine detail that exists
images you need to be able to fool
humans that a synthetic image was was
real basically and that takes a lot of
difficulty so basically actually how
much annexed to that question is for
generative modeling there's you use
where's energy these in general or lots
of computers require basically unless
you I mean if you're doing I guess you
could do some sort of generative
modeling that is not trying to be very
sophisticated but things slightly and
Gans or I don't know people still use
yeah
so yes sir yeah right oh I haven't
thought about having other cameras but I
think one thing that would be
interesting is again would be out of
drones that had like a bunch of cameras
all around like one of the what are they
call a three-dimensional 360 oh thank
you 360 cube right you know I do object
detection in 316 you know using your
phone's hardware yeah that's the only
bad at me pretty cool one of those
amazing things I saw I was on the bus
not too long ago and a blind person had
what looked like a prank phone hanging
from shirt and the phone said person in
front of you three really pull her yes
and I was going Wow and I thought I'd
talk to Francis oh yeah that's an
application it cost a lot of money
whatever you need do it Wow but I said
from what you I'll give you a commercial
application of what you or your app that
you know people who can't see properly
or whatever needs to walk around
something like that will do the job
perfectly well for them
you know where you don't need it's not
like driving where he needs to this
super instantaneous response but they
can do for that and that I think that
actually said there was a person in
front of you or something like that
right but you could go further there's a
girl in front of you you could increase
that app so that a blind person can use
their phone as their eyes I mean the
technology's there it's actually not
that far away from that yeah it's really
yeah amazing how many things are already
possible it's just
yeah but I've actually been thinking of
doing was have a bunch of ideas but I
don't like talking about ideas because
not because I'm afraid of anyone taking
them but I think a lot of it's not way I
think a lot of the best ideas at first
they sound kind of silly or stupid but
also it's just a matter of exploring try
something simple out putting it out
there see how people used it and then
but like what little thing that I've
actually I that I would like to make is
something similar to I guess what
perhaps already exists okay well they
did but there's something actually then
then say just using the camera actually
generated sounds that correspond to what
it sees so say like if you just want to
have hearing when you're driving like
pointing your camera at a different
direction or something and just
constantly be even have it plugged into
your car's system if you just have like
some additional input like through one
sense while you're looking at the road
with your eyes whether you can actually
get feedback through sound that
something that another observer feeling
your a phone or app is doing that thing
like inform you about your surroundings
and similarly with like like when
fighting or something I don't know I
think a lot of situations that you think
of they seem kind of not as useful
because we have a bias for thinking of
applications that technology already
accomplished
and there's kind of this like
chicken-and-egg all about what is what
is an application that doesn't exist yet
like we don't think of because
technology hasn't been able to achieve
it for us before so watch science
fiction movies yeah that's a what to do
so
I'll take one more question so one is
tracking which I think actually would be
pretty doable is that reminds me I have
much reading into how how they're
tracking where it's been a magistrate
it's similar to how the two-stage author
protectors work where they have a an
initial guess that flows through with
additional current information then
updates the guess you know probably like
they're tracking like okay there's this
dog this dog mint and there's a new
frame of the next frame of video those
300 me that the still the same dog and I
thought that is doable but as far as
like this variety in the scene what
comes to after that is like a scene
captioning which involves like
describing qualitatively in words what
is happening in a screen that is work
located as it involves and that it's
frigates going from an image to a
sequence at least just thinking in terms
of like you said could you create
something back describe a situation
where there's a dog running I don't know
or go about that birds or how come here
to be your Google you need to compress
some of those scene captioning bottles
into a smaller version because they be
used for current deaths in addition to
the convolutions have you ever seen some
of this work got like automated captions
veneration for images it's used by
Facebook and Google like when you look
up a restaurant or something on Google
Maps they have that little caption like
trendy bar with you know ability or
something that's an automatically
generated captions based on images
people in the business and it's like a
certain type of model and everything but
I don't know but thank you so much for
your time
[Applause]